something that you that you always find
is the sort of old school wisdom whether
it's from uh the Bible or it's from
another biblical text or whatever around
all these different problems uh there's
there's a lot of wisdom there right
people look at it like oh this is just
you know this was written thousands of
years ago it's not valid whatever you
know why why do men want virgins men
just want virgins because they're you
know they're misogynists and they're
sexist and they want to impress me and
it's like well you know you can look at
like you said you can pull up studies
you can pull up data and you can be like
okay well look we've literally got a
chart do you argue with that and it's
like okay so maybe maybe the people back
in those days may not have been able to
perfectly articulate the reason for
certain norms and so it's also very very
different back then too because we
didn't have things like social media
like men and women use social media very
very differently don't we like men will
use a camera and they'll point it
outwards and take a picture of their car
a landscape women take a picture of
themselves you know they turn the camera
around the other way and they take
selfies in every country too in every
country yeah you know cross-culturally
every country and you know if you give
women uh unlimited access to a screen
where other men are on their screens as
well and they're showering these women
with unlimited validation and attention
you're beautiful you go girl so strong
and brave it doesn't matter if they're a
two or a ten they all hear the same
message you know even a even an average
looking woman will be told online that
she's amazing and you know with the
addition of filters and angles and Spanx
and all these other you know new
technologies and stuff like that you can
really boost the system but women today
are
have have so much access to so much more
than what we did 100 years ago it's the
same thing with men too you like men
also have the same advantages and the
same disadvantages it's just that social
media I think uh is used very very
differently by men and women you know
like women will use to amplify certain
characteristics and and traits and men
will use it for other like only fans
wouldn't exist if there wasn't simps if
there wasn't a simp economy with men
struggling with women looking for
attention and validation from women
giving them money for that it just
wouldn't exist and you have these women
now today who are making fifty thousand
a hundred thousand dollars a month
taking pictures of themselves in ways
that you can just go to Google and
search for or go to a porn site or
something like that now right yeah it's
very weird I mean if and if we're
talking numbers
then men are a bigger percentage of that
problem because for every because for
every one of those girls there's
hundreds of men who are paying for for
that individual to show them that I
don't know who all these men are but
they're clearly out there otherwise
there wouldn't be uh those figures
wouldn't be possible yeah whenever I
talk about that I always have guys that
chime in and they say well you know like
when are we going to hold these men
accountable and say if you have a
solution to simping I would like to know
what it is because I don't know how to
solve that problem it's rampant like you
you're not going to stop guys from
sipping I don't think
yeah it's a it's it's a weird time it's
a it's a very weird time to be living in
um I think another problem with the
technology and again I think people who
have been you know been in long-term
relationships marriages for let's say
10 plus 10 plus it's certainly 15 plus
years don't get is just the the level of
the technological impact on both on both
men and women because another thing it
does is it creates um
I would say it's like a
it creates a sense of artificial options
maybe that's the best way to put it
right so I think from the male
perspective if you're on you know
Instagram Instagram in particular but
social media in general and you're just
seeing all these women all over the
world all these places and you know
you're interacting with some or whatever
you know okay like I don't know myself I
have
across social media I must have around
700 to 800 000 female followers
right so you can have this idea of like
oh there's
there's so many options right or a girl
you know any cute girl can have 10 000
plus followers on Instagram easily yeah
easily right some of them hundreds of
thousands and so it can have this idea
oh I've got all these men and you know
men are liking and men are simping and
they're commenting or whatever and so
it's like oh I have all these options of
a potential boyfriend or a potential
husband or whatever not realizing that
no like there's a lot of guys who would
be you know they'll happily sleep with
you or you know maybe they'll date you
or not take you seriously or whatever
but out of that pool of men what
percentage who meet your who meet your
bar your female bar are also like taking
you seriously enough that they're like
oh okay I would actually consider
marrying this woman and committing to
her and so on so I think there's this
Paradox of choice that can happen on
both sides where people think like oh my
gosh like you know I never settle right
that's why I say you know you never
never settle never settle never settle
it's like well the reality is that
people do settle right like if you if if
you're picking one thing it means your
sessions yes if you're not if you're if
you pick one thing you know if you go to
a restaurant and you order something on
the menu it means you're not eating
every single everything else it tastes
really good it's probably not vegan has
a lot of sugar and some fat I'm sure I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out